hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on appelle le retournement de
perruques donc attention
rudy tu te retournes et un moment je
vais t'appeler je veux dire rudy tu
regarderas la période jusqu'à la fin
d'émission les retours de thouars bitume
et les vélos rue guiraud dit pas ce qui
te l'a retrouvée cassée choc assez vite
attends tu la mettes dodo fauteuil un
tannant tournoi tu fais dodo et et et
toi comme toi je te vois plus son
indochine toi attention c'est parti à
parent alors on démarre par rudy vous
dis je vais t'appeler un attention sans
crédit sera lui à l'état aussi
heureusement que je marquais redis c'est
la céruse il mais il a deux essais tu
gagnes la totale d'accord sur lui oui
oui oui attention ses parents le
caméraman âge un peu peur bleue
caméraman faut qu'il fasse gaffe le
shérif attention c'est parti
non attention déjà laissé redonner le
ballon autonome
ce pour l'attenté perdu mais je vais
essayer d'un berceau merde série les
chéris on va faire un dernier truc
puisqu'il une table de ping pong
si si je bats rudy gobert au ping pong
sur trois points
tu repars avec tous les cadeaux d'accord
la série les piliers hockey soit et
donnait libre ou l'autre à table il est
plus grand que la table à laisser enfin
enfin point des ces gens feront bon
teint kg est pas à mon avis c'était la
balle d'essai non et ouais faut être bon
il faut pas être bon à l'entraînement
faux pas devant répète aurait dit je me
suis remis en jeu serbe au bonus à trois
points gagnants
baj
attends je porte de nox 1 0 bon tu peux
déjà préparer ta valise
j'ai alors bataille
ta gueule pas trouvé pas mal c'est vrai
il ya des gros bras attention il n'aime
pas mon service j'ai tout de suite vu ne
reflète plus jamais ça oui saguenay la
gagne je crois que c'est gagné